boys 2 men are coming in what's going on
we're on the air how are you how are you
sir I tell you why do you guys are
coming in time making sure that all the
microphones are we don't care you're on
doesn't matter right yeah I am breaking
stuff okay let's just make sure I didn't
[ __ ] this up or you want to sir oh
that's right the Sirius XM so you can
cuss and I saw the sign for you is it
the Mirage where you are yes sir we are
in the Mirage Hotel and Casino for the
last four and a half years we have
another two and a half years left yeah
Wow
so do you like a residency I always
wanted to forget boring and this
stability of any type is a great thing
and the fact that before that we used to
do a bunch of international travel like
every single week so the fact that we
got a venue where everybody comes from
all around the world to one room every
weekend is a different crowd it's a
beautiful thing that's gotta be pretty
great yeah so what do you do do you guys
all just live in Vegas now no we can be
back and forth we commute we commute
different parts you know Jersey la
Florida but we get around what nights
you're working if you're commuting from
Jersey Sunday so residences like you
know boy you got to do like you know a
ten o'clock show Sunday and then a but I
think somebody forgot that we sing for a
living and it's very difficult to sing
to shows as hard as we go into in two
days so we decide to go with the gist
Friday Saturday Sunday don't know we try
no we try you know just know it's just
one of those things where we because
we're singers we don't lip-sync it the
same way so we would screw it up you
know you know what the track would be
one thing and wine yet would be doing
something over here and it wouldn't
matter
never do like the same thing like maybe
like you might hear the same thing like
maybe twice but not the third fourth
time you'd be like okay so it would
never like match never do you get
frustrated when you see other groups
that are like obviously lip-synching
like it seems my big adieu never been a
thing that you know it's it's cool for
them and it works for them or whatever
but like you know it's almost like if
somebody said man you jealous that do
smoking crack do you guys ever have to
I'm sure you do like where where if it's
a solo singer if the voices and I'm sure
one of you guys will have a night where
your voice is not good
no you're cracking so your guys will
just pick it up oh yeah we shuffle parts
around a lot I mean another thing too as
we do Vegas on the weekends but we do
like a bunch of different corporate
stuff I mean like this weekend we're not
in Vegas but we're doing an event on DC
for United Way so we kind of jump around
and do a lot of different stuff like
that throughout the week so we may not
even go home that we may do Vegas or on
Friday Saturday Sunday and then we're
somewhere else Monday Tuesday Wednesday
and then right back to Vegas I'm sorry
how do you guys all maintain friendships
in a band it's so difficult I know we
talked about in fascinated by bands that
can make it work and I know Michael
McCary is out of the band with a group
but how do you guys do it without
fighting among each other Oh for that
job we definitely you know we hash out
our problems in with conversations and
argument every now and then but um you
know we respect each other and we're
brothers you know I'm saying just like
anybody any family that might get into
something and you know clear it up
because we know what we're our goal is
to love one another and to do music so
this is really uh it's really a simple
thing just respect somebody and then may
let them be who they are any
relationship the smartest thing to learn
is to learn to agree to disagree a lot
of people say that they know how to do
that but they'll disagree and then I
walk away and they'll carry something
you know we understand that we're not
gonna agree all the time and you know
we'll argue it out to the to the end I
mean almost like you know heartfully to
where it seems like it's escalating but
at the end of the day when a guy knows
that the other guy's not budging and the
other guys not budging we just don't
agree
okay you guys Sara what's more important
here winning the argument or possibly
we're just going all right well
fortunately we don't have a bunch of
guys that like we all think we're right
like that's what breaks groups apart
like you got one guy that says you know
I'm right and you got another guy that
says do you I'm right you know that
whole thing and and they break up so
it's just one of those things where you
kind of like you you have to have some
level of compromise and take away two
ego cuz this industry entertainment
industry not just musing but acting
comedy Tohono it's you know it's built
on sometimes inflated egos and things
that nature and sometimes it can kind of
run amok and when you argue about the
most like wow what is that what is the
thing that it's very different tapia
it's different topics and different
things we have to face every day so
there might be certain things that one
person might you know creative smallest
and didn't like Sean it even depends on
how you feel that day it might be
something you may not even think about
arguing about that day but because
you're in a certain mood that bothers
you so it kind of it's like a family
thing it's like I said man sometimes so
much is going anywhere when you learn to
agree to disagree
it helps things move along and you just
go along with it now you guys are all
single are you married I am you're
saying okay so you're like still
enjoying cuz you know let's be honest I
mean you guys still have women that will
come and see you in groupies who've been
fans I don't I mean I enjoy I enjoy a
bit in relationships and things like
that for me right now I just I enjoy
being at a point in my life where I'm
not I'm not women always get crazy when
you say oh he just doesn't want to be
obligated I don't think obligated is a
bad word it's okay to be obligated but
at the end of the day I'm more obligated
to these guys I grew up with for the
last 26 years of my life anything that
comes in my life comes after them and
there are some people that can deal with
that and there's some people that can't
so at the end of the day for me as long
as I got my guys I can figure out
everything else did you throw your crazy
times don't worry where you were just
running amuck and banging everything yes
yeah we yeah yeah we did we were young
we did crazy stuff I mean we just you
know it wasn't the internet age so you
didn't find out everything that we did
and
you know we were we were literally boys
to men and we were doing boys to men
stuff so now we're we're men and we have
the Internet and we're not gonna let you
know what it was ever doing boys to men
stuff like all at the same time or was
it separate it was ever a girl who
walked out feeling like I don't know why
I just did that random chick to come out
of nowhere
is it weird someone coming back 20 years
later circumstance but I mean as a
person you I think it really depends on
the situation yeah there are some
situations that traumatize people to the
point where they're not able to come out
in that way and then there are some
situations where some people ie Monica
Lewinsky that just sit around and wait
so I mean there's always people on
different sides of the fence but yeah
weird to like you you're in a band and
you're famous and let's say you had a
girl one night back in 2001 and you
didn't know that she wasn't a hundred
percent on board but she was just a fan
like you have no way of knowing cuz
you're like come on and she's like all
right yeah and then she I feel bad about
that you don't know anything you say to
yourself you know what let's just say
something did happen you don't want to
lie about it but you didn't know that it
happened I don't know she wasn't cool
with it one has an alternative I mean
just more so my thing was always if you
if you create a connection you know what
I mean some sort of dialogue
understanding that this is what the
circumstances are and you don't divert
from that you know what I'm saying most
of the times you know they you know
someone comes to your room came to your
room they came to your room to you know
do whatever but you know if you bring
them up to you on false pretenses or
make them you know watch your new video
you know you know what you know what you
about to do right we're not here to
listen your music yes I know they have
understanding you have an understanding
and then you create a friendship that
way because you don't start the whole
thing off with a lie you don't want to
the only tough part is that sometimes
those preachers are set up but then you
got those people who are a little bit
left that their intentions weren't
really that it was something else
you kind of got caught in it well
systems perfect you got a bet amount
I've never gotten robbed my guys you did
rob per se I mean I've watched a man
[Laughter]
take it out of your room but not like
robbed like right up to you like hey
give it to me Connor I have okay where
were you it was in Philly Philly and
yeah it was in Philly and it was in my
old neighborhood how crazy is that
and these guys know right I've known him
for 30 years now there was these guys I
guess that was following us me and uh my
security at the time and he got
understand like at that time I think the
only three guys in Philadelphia that had
a v12 s600
was myself Nathan and Allen Iverson and
and so so I'm driving one summer day and
this black Volvo cuts us off it's four
guys jump out wit guns
well basically telling us you know run
your [ __ ] give me your [ __ ] money
give me what you know going crazy and
they know which one else do you or
didn't know they thought because they
kept asking where's the money they
thought I was a drug dealer I guess drug
dealers driving around with a bunch of
money in the back of a trunk so you know
so you know they took my earrings they
took my chain they ran my pockets or
whatever and they took my car but before
they took my car
the guy had the gun to my chest and his
boys was egging them on shoot that
[ __ ] shoot him and when all this
was going on it's a weird
place your in when that happens you're
not scared you're more like in shock
sure like wow this don't happen to me
like this this stuff you see on
television like you don't you you don't
get robbed like this like this is none
and he had the gun right to my chest
obviously he didn't shoot me but he he
hopped in the car drove off for about a
block and then got out the car cuz he
probably realized that with that car
they would've got picked up and - sure
so they got out the car and jet it but
yeah I got robbed so when you know you
were already obviously in the group
you're famous is there a moment for you
where you want to go hey I'm in this
group like not to do it you know no it
was more or less I was more or less I
was more or less just trying to get them
out of my face it was more or less like
do take the car I'll get enough and I
hit take the car take whatever you need
just just take it and roll when but
don't shoot me don't see how offensive
is that that the guys are encouraging
other leg and Megan this fool with the
gun too much you know what I mean I
brought up and and unfortunately you not
I mean there's there's innocent people
that are you not I mean that are caught
up and in their their you know their
their mind you know the craziness and
their minds and it's just saying when
was this this was this was like 94 95 so
it was right but right in right right
right but you know what though it taught
me a lot it first off it made me realize
it yo I came out of fairly well that was
one cuz I did leave yeah but that was
years later but you know to just be
careful out here because know people
don't care and it's even worse now
people don't really care people look at
other celebrities and other artists as
food so they don't care they don't care
who you are whatever they get if they
get an opportunity to to gank you they
will
you just got to be careful out here
buddy of mine in Brooklyn he's a
comedian he said that Slick Rick was
doing a thing was it's one of the
projects in Brooklyn he was performing
and guys were getting together they
wanted to rob him and some some big
gangster from the the wherever they were
said you can't he came to entertain you
right right Robert but it wasn't for
that guy they were gonna rob him coming
out it's filling all these are roughly
did any of you guys ever think of
because like some of the best boxers in
the world come from Philly right any of
the guys ever trained not professionally
but it seems like you have to be able to
fight if you grow so I mean I kind of
didn't have a choice it was in fact the
roughest area Philly well actually north
south kinda like on that one that border
wine came out of the three of us wine
came from the toughest it's one of those
areas where you got to know I mean
either either let's put this way if you
if you don't you're going to by the time
you become a certain age because it's it
just happens every day you're gonna get
beaten up if you don't like it you fight
and figure it out and they leave you
alone same thing your mom always said
you bet you better go or not yeah they
gonna do it every year literally you're
literally thrown into the fight like you
gotta fight there's certain places
certain moments where you got a knuckle
up or you know well you probably don't
all or no they try to when I was younger
I did but I mean like I said I learned
fast I mean I used to live in South West
Philly when I moved to South Philly it
was a different ball game for me I mean
Jews is fighting every single day I had
no choice it was like you either you
either get in it or you just gonna be
the one getting beat up every day so I
wouldn't stand for that having your
lunch money whatever taking yeah yeah so
when you guys start singing like was
there any part of you or any member of
the group that was like no we can't do
this like singing stuff we have to do
something with like bravado we got a
tough guy I'm gonna tell you like
because I come from Southwest Philly and
I still go to like to Philadelphia Boys
Choir which you know if anybody knows
anything about that is one of the
whitest things you could ever do but as
a black kid so you know you you know I
would take the train into the Broad
Street sub and all this less to two
hours to get to this place and my
neighborhood friends knew that I did
that and they encouraged me they were
like yo man you know do it like you got
a voice you got a talent
again yeah yeah it's Brown was the exact
opposite thing I was leaving mine my
ghetto to do that and it wasn't like his
I wish it was like here's what he
encouraged me it was like you know why
are you going away so you look like
you're selling out you're leaving in
with you the guys are saying
it's great they would say were totally
cool with it I mean yeah I wrapped a
little bit too but you know I also sang
and and they were cool with it and it
was fine especially when you know they
found out that you know we got a record
deal of course you had a couple of
naysayers are you nicely you you ain't
signed to know Motown Records man you
know that whole thing but you know even
then like they came around to say y'all
will be proud of you you know and that
was that Motown record first yeah that
was our first labor projects he's alive
you know different for me but my
grandmother my mom they always kept me
away from they didn't want me to go to
school down there where I lived they
didn't want me to go to do the direct
direct centers where everybody when I
went to like freedom hitter and you know
a bunch of like you know Martin Luther
King type stuff you know whose and it
was just everything black black black
and I was cool with it but I like just
the artistic expression of it all you
know what I'm saying you know I'm you
know I grew up in the hood I mean that's
that's where I'm from you know what I
mean that's just the hood is where I
grew up but the mentality was not born
and bred in me it was of course survival
was was the key you know I mean but
under the circumstances it was more so
you know you know that it was a stepping
stone to I knew that there was something
else you know what I mean because my
parents my grandmother and my mom and
all that people that you know Miss
Virginia and all these people that lived
in that area they always wanted me to do
something different because I had an
exceptional gift do you know Plus once
like once you start having hits and
you're still kind of shouting out where
you're from and still not like you know
denying that part and then bringing you
know going back to where you grew up for
the videos and stuff like that that's
one thing about us is we tried to bring
them along I mean
yeah no matter what we went through in
the streets I mean in everything we've
gone through we've gone through we
understand that without those things
they wouldn't have made us to human
beings that we are
I mean we all go through good things and
bad things and without fili
you know our personality you know who we
are you know ours perseverance our being
able to overcome when things don't go
well I mean the streets taught us a lot
to do what we do why'd you say Philly
rejected you though I mean it was just
like a lot of things that we would want
to do in Philly
I guess in the beginning they didn't
really believe too much so we would want
to do like videos a certain place isn't
he like no I think it was really under
the industry is so misunderstood like in
many aspects like a lot of people think
that oh you're signed to a record deal
you're rich or they'll say certain
things about the industry well you can't
do that because we don't want this to
happen and there's so many
misconceptions about the game so I think
Philadelphia which is an old town and
it's run it was run by a bunch of old
people they didn't really get this they
didn't really understand what a music
video was and why you need to block out
a street and so a lot of those concepts
was still fairly new to the civilian
world but yeah I remember to the issue
too is that it had a lot to do with
urban artists as well because there were
people shooting in Philly
you know and it just weren't you know
urban artists and instantly you see a
black group you think all they're gonna
come in here well yeah hip-hop riff
Raff's a lot of it took us trying to
prove to them that that's not wheat
we're R&B singers we sing you know I'm
saying so like once and it was a while
for them to jump on board to understand
that we weren't what they so-called
thought offensive were offensive to any
of anything at that point and you guys
have a new new album coming out tomorrow
it's called under the streetlight and
you're gonna be at Barnes & Noble on
Fifth Avenue and tomorrow at noon for a
meet and greet photo-op is the 5th
Avenue Barnes no but that's not the one
in Union Square is it but no where is
the 5th Avenue you don't live here
between Broad Street and a
I thought down did you did you ever get
this now that you're at this place where
you've got the show in Vegas and you do
a corporate gig I mean the money must be
incredible when you when you said if
there's corporate gigs - but did you get
to a place where like you're like I
never want to perform end of the road
again I never want to do Motown feels
like see here's the thing here's the
thing I'm gonna tell you this and I'm
not saying that we don't get tired I
think we just get tired but let's let's
let's let's be honest we are three black
guys from Philadelphia that's how we
promote our show and the odds and the
odds of us succeeding were slim to none
we were blessed to have a hit record
that charted for thirteen weeks and beat
Elvis Presley's record we will sing that
song until our voices go out that is the
truth like that we are we understand the
value of what has happened to us and we
do not take it for granted so a lot of
times you hear at least at some point in
people's careers like they start to feel
entitled about what pale innopolis and
they don't do they lose perspective on
that that this wasn't supposed to happen
26 you get fatigued but you know you
don't get stupid right you know you guys
are you ranked fourth all-time for a
time spent at number one and it's just
it's phenomenal special man I mean it's
things that we never really thought
about until we kind of I guess we say
kind of taking a step out of the so
called recording business because we
make records but we're really in the
performing business and um you look back
and you look at stuff like that 16 weeks
13 weeks 14 weeks I mean I saw almost 52
weeks it's almost a whole year number
one so I mean there's you there things
now that we share with our kids that we
never thought about back then because we
always just focused on getting the
rehearsal being the best group we could
be sounding different than anybody else
and we never cared about anything else
so people always ask when you look back
you know did you have time to enjoy it
we asked some time but
now we have more time than ever to look
back and see the things that we've done
and the guy left Mike McAra left your
band why did he leave the band there
were a few reasons one first off Mike
always he never really had the same
Drive as we did like he kind of got into
this somewhat by default like he had a
low voice he had a bass note that made
our harmonies sound amazing and isn't
it's not to discredit his involvement
with the group cuz he was a huge part of
what boys to men you know was at first
but again the love just wasn't there as
much and it started to show throughout
the years not to mention physically he
had like some ailments that his back
gradually took him out of it where he
didn't even want to do it more and it
just got to a point where we we had to
make a decision and it's a literal
marriage is one of those things where
you know there are people that say their
vows you know through good and bad and
sickness and health death do us part
and they stay there and then there are
some that break those vows and are not
there for the good times in the bad
times it is there for the good times and
that's kind of where we cuz you know
that you know just you know jump in
there was some times where things
weren't all that good you know what I
mean it was we went through some really
humbling experiences community when
things kind of was hard and and you know
we we we were supposed to stick together
in that you know I suppose you know kind
of like you know brought it out and you
know like we're doing right now we're
doing you know to me and we did that you
know what I mean and while we were
working in hustling and trying to make
it happen
he wasn't there okay yeah and under
circumstances you don't come to work and
unfortunately you just don't yeah how do
you saw how do you have that
conversation where you tell a guy you
have to leave like gee do you say well
all three of us are gonna get together
does he know it's coming or what's that
moment one thing about us is that we we
never hid anything from anybody I mean
we'll tell you straight up because
that's that's what's kept us grounded
and together for 26 years is that I can
say whatever I need to say to any one of
them and they can say it to me and we
don't really care
what your response is because this is
just how we feel so we were able to
address that with him that kind of like
Juan said I mean you're not pulling your
weight you need to do you need to do the
things that need to be done or otherwise
you know it's gonna be a problem for us
we've got to do something different and
then you know he kind of disappeared and
kind of extinguishes itself in a way but
there was an option there like if he
would sit all right yeah I know you guys
just come just okay yeah it was yeah it
was he just he just decided I think in
his head he almost felt it was kind of
what you guys were saying earlier about
the little ego thing I think in his mind
he felt that okay they're going to need
me and that didn't happen yet and I mean
not me right it was it was a struggle
creating the identity around the three
but it's weird when you look at our
career after 26 years you and you
probably don't understand but mike has
been away longer than we've been a group
in other words he left in 2000 that's
almost 18 years ago yeah
and that's interesting too because like
you said there is this kind of dip and
then if you can hold out you come back
because people remember like oh you know
what was great and then and then you can
wait but the last thing you want is the
guy that wasn't there is that you know
during that time of course there were
doubts in our minds but you know like
you said you stick in there and you know
you take that ride the way back up the
reason why we stuck around and all
honesty and sounds cliche and you know
you might think we're bullcrapping man
but it's the fans this it's like
remembering the smiles remembering the
tears remembering you know people coming
up to you and saying you know your music
saved our lives and realizing that it
was definitely it wasn't us
it was the music and it was God that you
know gave us these records and gave us
the ability to be able to touch people
in and honestly I mean we broke up like
numerous times like five minutes each
time people and the only reason why we
decided to stay together is because we
knew we had
you know well first of all we love the
way we sound together you know that I
don't think we would ever find out with
anybody else and also just just
remembering the fan it is it sounds it
sounds kind of it is true what was
saying but it even sounds like kind of
weird to even mention these things
because thanks to social media in just
the world status in general like
everything's become so callous and
everything is not as everything has to
be ratchet and everything has to be raw
and all these other like demeaning and
crazy things you know I'm saying because
normally a person would say no I was
about the money that's why we stayed
together and I was like but honestly the
truth is is that is what I really said
but it still sounds kind of weird
because listening to things and hearing
how the status of just entertainment is
everything is just so opposite now there
was no there was no real money to stick
around right so it wasn't about the
money
jobs individually a man for money